coffee on a Friday and the project for
awesome this is the earth it goes around
the Sun this is what it looks like up
close
this is America this is Los Angeles this
is a school this is a classroom these
are desks here are some American
children here they are in class here is
their teacher here is one student being
told that the earth goes around the Sun
here he is being told that there are 300
billion stars in the galaxy here is
being told that one thimbleful of a
neutron star would weigh over 100
million tons here is getting into MIT
here he is graduating magna laude
here he is unraveling the mysteries of
quantum entanglement and understanding
the key to how plants collect store and
use energy from the Sun at 100 percent
efficiency here are super efficient
photovoltaic solar cells that his
physics helped to create here they are
powering the city here they are powering
a nation
here is the boy receiving the Nobel
Prize here he is on a Sunday afternoon
with his family here he is thinking back
over his life about how everything he's
done everything he is he owes to that
first science teacher who told him about
the earth and how it goes around the Sun
but the boy who is now an old man would
be wrong he's forgetting something
something he would never think of
something that predicated the Nobel
Prize in the solar cells in the physics
and MIT and his excitement that day all
those years ago about a thimbleful of
neutron star the boy is forgetting the
desks
this is the earth again this is Africa
this is a country in Africa called
Malawi this is a school this is a
classroom there are no desks here are
some children in pain from sitting on
the dirt floor for eight hours a day and
here is one being told that the earth
goes around the Sun here is where I tell
you that learning is like a mountain
it's hard at first to climb harder for
some but once you reach the peak it
becomes self-perpetuating and fun and
transformative on and on for the rest of
your life here is how much it would cost
to get that boy a desk here is how much
it would cost to get the whole classroom
desks here is how much you have to
donate here are what the desks look like
here are how many children the desks can
see here are how many children usually
sit at one here are how many children
will sit at your desk in its lifetime
here is the limit of what someone can do
when they love to learn here is my
charity
here is where you can read more about it
here is where you can do
you